- As morbid as it sounds, nobody knows
when they're gonna die.
I'm fucked.
I find that a little terrifying,
and I just wanna shove my
life full of experiences
before it's too late.
So I'm gonna get as much of
my bucket list done as I can
in one week.
Something new every day.
(upbeat music)
I only have one week, so no big traveling.
Marriage and kids, not
gonna do that this week.
Go to outer space is just not
super realistic right now,
so that's gone.
After taking everything
into account I'm left with
six items: learn to skateboard,
write a children's novel,
get a tattoo, tell my
parents how much I love them,
skydive, and play with a monkey.
All right, let's go do it!
(triumphant music)
Today I'm learning to skateboard.
I have my helmet and my
elbow pads and I got a board.
As well as my friend Steven
who's gonna teach me.
- I really hope Megan falls.
- My main goal for today is to
skateboard from here at work
to the Arclight which is
where I park sometimes.
Bucket list number one, let's go.
I can do this.
(relaxed music)
- Okay.
That's something to start with.
(screaming)
(indistinct sped up talking)
(upbeat music)
Yeah.
I think we can move on.
You wanna go out front, hit some curbs?
- Could we say another
word other than hit?
Oh, why am I so nervous?
- You're gonna be fine.
- What's that thing?
- A curb.
- No, no, there's a thing in the road.
This, it's a leaf, okay.
- Any other excuses?
- Nope.
Ready, set.
Skater girl!
Am I fast?
(squeals)
Okay, that was easy.
I did it guys, it's over.
Bye!
(doo wop music)
I'm in the gutter, cuz I'm trash.
(screaming)
- That was good.
- I can't skate to
the Arclight constantly going (wailing).
(chuckles) People will be so concerned.
We'll just do it like once or twice more,
I can't imagine why I'd
need more than that.
(playful music)
(screams)
I'm feeling very discouraged.
This is just way more challenging
than I thought it would be.
I can hardly stand on the freaking board.
Okay let's go.
I'm ready.
Okay, the time has come.
I'm gonna do it.
It's all the way down there,
seemingly into the oblivion.
But into the oblivion we go.
(beeping)
(hip hop music)
♫ What's the time, what's the time
♫ It's time to tantivy
♫ Tantivy
♫ Come on it's no time to hide
♫ You got to tantivy
♫ It's time to tantivy
I think I'm about halfway there.
♫ No time to hide, it's time to tantivy
♫ Relax no more
♫ It's time to roll
(horns honking)
♫ We got to rise on up
♫ We got to take our place
Thank you.
(uplifting music)
I'm exhausted.
I feel like some people
will watch this video
and just be like, "Big deal."
(chuckles)
But I was scared, this is like
what I was most afraid to do
and I did it.
Day one is done.
Let's go write a children's book tomorrow.
I've always wanted to
write a children's novel
so I could give back to kids what I got
out of these books.
I guess I've never gone
through with this because
I just didn't think I was creative enough.
If I die and I haven't
written a children's novel,
that's one more thing that I
would regret not having done.
I think I want it to
be about mental health.
I feel like a lot of adults
still don't understand
certain aspects of mental
health, so I figure,
let's start 'em young,
taking about depression.
I'm not kidding, this
book is about depression,
but it's gonna be great.
(lively music)
Oh! (chuckles)
I did it!
I titled my book Rita Rabbit
and the Invisible Injury.
I don't have a ton of
children that I can share
my story with at this moment,
so I am going to round up
some coworkers and have story time.
Rita Rabbit, Foxy Felicia
and Trusty the Turtle
are all best friends.
They play every single day.
Rita Rabbit notices she hasn't been happy.
Oh I forgot to tell you,
this is about depression.
(crowd laughs)
- [Man] What a twist.
- Foxy Felicia and
Trusty the Turtle stop by
Rita the Rabbit's house,
but she shoos them away.
Foxy and Trusty get tired of
Rita Rabbit not joining them.
One day, Rita the Rabbit finds a
piece of paper on the ground.
It's an invitation to a party
Foxy and Trusty are throwing,
and Rita is not invited.
Rita goes to see Dr. Dolphin with her mom.
She hasn't been eating or sleeping.
The doctor explains that
Rita has depression,
an invisible injury that hurts the brain.
Dr. Dolphin explains that
even though you can't see
the broken parts on the outside,
the hurt that depression
causes to your insides
can be just as painful
and difficult to heal.
Felicia and Trusty ask how they can help.
Rita asks for patience and understanding
and for the friends to know
that depression is an injury
Rita might be working on for a long time.
With a deeper understand,
their friendship flourishes.
The end.
(crowd applauds)
- [Woman] Aw!
- Okay.
Day two is over.
This is gonna be a real book shortly.
Link below to buy.
Tomorrow, I get a tattoo.
I haven't thought a lot about the pain.
(rock music)
I'm so excited but I also feel very ill.
I brought my boyfriend
and my best friend here
for moral support.
I guess the reason I've
never gotten a tattoo is
fear of regretting it later.
It's fine, lasers.
No.
To the chair.
- Yeah, what are you
gonna get tattooed today?
- I'm actually getting
a piece of advice that
my friend Mallory gave
me, which is, lean in.
- I remember her sitting
at my kitchen table.
She was telling me, "I
don't know what to do.
"I just want to take this big leap into
"this new adventure," and I told her,
you just gotta lean in.
Lean into the fear and do it
even though it scares you,
cuz it's gonna be worth it.
- Okay, let's do it.
There's gonna be a lot of
talking, I talk when I'm nervous,
I also ask a lot of questions.
- You good?
- No, no, no.
No, no, no.
Wait, wait.
- Good talk, okay.
- No, no, no, no!
- Ready?
- Yeah.
- All right, here we go.
(needle buzzing)
One dot.
- Are you kidding?
- That's it.
- You serious?
- Yeah.
- That couldn't have been it, do it again.
(chuckles)
(needle buzzing)
- [Awz] How's that?
- (chuckles) Oh wow.
I'm gonna be addicted after
this, cuz it's not nearly
as painful as I thought it was.
I could so have a baby after this.
Oh, that's the pain.
Look, it's on my arm!
Here it is.
It's perfect, it's
exactly what I imagined.
(hands slap)
I'm halfway done with my bucket list.
Now I have a whole body
ready for more tattoos.
Let's do day four!
(upbeat music)
I'm at my parents' house right now.
If they die before I have
the chance to sit them down
and make sure that they understood
how much they mean to me
and how much I love them,
I would be devastated.
So today, we're gonna
make sure that I never
have to regret that.
I brought you here to our kitchen table.
Relax.
This part of my bucket
list was to tell you both
how much I love you.
I know that people have their
parents die and they're like,
I wish I could just
tell them one last time
how much I love them, and I
never wanna have that regret,
so, I just wanted to tell you guys.
- This is my death thank you?
- (chuckles) Yes.
I didn't write a speech, I
don't have anything planned,
that was kind of it.
(chuckles)
Don't die.
- I don't plan on it anytime soon.
- But we will hold onto
this forever and ever.
- I love you.
- Let's go eat lunch.
(rock music)
Today I'm skydiving.
Diving from the sky.
Up there, onto planet Earth.
I brought my mom, come here mom.
Why did you insist on coming?
- Because of the chances you take
and that you follow your heart.
- Okay, go away.
This isn't the time for emotional shit.
This is the time to jump from the sky.
Let's do it!
Freeze frame.
(suspenseful orchestral music)
Saying goodbye to my
mom, possibly forever.
Just kidding.
(rock music)
- Go Megan!
(screams)
- Bye.
- [Megan's Mom] Meggy!
- [Man] Welcome back down to Earth!
- Holy shit.
(groans) I wanna lie down.
I don't feel my legs.
Y'all, oh my god.
You leave the plane and
you're just fucking falling,
like I've never experienced
anything like that
where you really are just like falling.
The camera guy kept
grabbing my hand, like,
"Yeah, smile," I was
like, "I can't smile!"
I am still processing it.
(rock music)
Tomorrow's the day that
we play with monkeys.
(grunts excitedly)
We're gonna wash 'em,
we're gonna diaper 'em,
it's gonna be so fun.
(playful music)
It's day six.
It's the last day of the bucket
list, I can't believe it.
This is something that
was on the top of my
first bucket list, and I
can't believe that I get to
make that dream come true today.
Oh my god, it's a monkey.
And I was told they're very
attracted to color and sparkle,
which is why I put all of this on.
This is gonna be a great day.
Let's get down to some monkey business.
Oh my god, I'm gonna cry.
- This is Squirt.
And Squirt here is gonna put
on her little bathing belt.
You go ahead and jump in that bath.
- Oh my god, it's a whole sink of monkeys.
I don't know what to do.
(upbeat music)
Hi.
- [Stacy] So what you wanna do, Megan,
is tell her you love her.
(smacks lips)
Give her lip smacks.
That's love.
When people smile at a
monkey, that's aggression.
- Oh no, I've been so aggressive.
He is having a grand old time.
- [Stacy] The one with the
funny hair do is Squirt.
- Squirt!
- And she's 23 years old.
- Wow, oh my god, we could be friends.
(smacks lips)
(mumbles in baby voice)
- [Stacy] All right Megan, have a seat.
Normally it takes awhile
for the monkeys to
warm up to you but he's already excited
about all your bling.
(playful music)
A little bit of monkey paw
tick's going on right now.
Squirt is telling Marley
not to touch the food.
(squeals)
(playful music)
- Oh, he's holding my hand.
He's holding my hand like a little baby.
Is this one keeping his
hand on me to say like,
you're my friend, don't pay
attention to anyone else?
- [Stacy] Yes, Mo likes
you, he's claiming you.
You're now his woman, Megan.
- Sorry, Jake.
- Hello my love.
Eveyrbody, this is Chrissy the baboon.
And Chrissy is 13 years old.
♫ Best friends forever, me and Squirt
♫ It's me and Squirt
forever starting right now
- This has been the
absolute best way to cap off
my bucket list.
My five year old self
and my 25 year old self
are so at peace.
What a great week, guys.
And those are all the words that I can
conjure in this moment.
(relaxed acoustic music)
This past week has been
an absolute whirlwind.
I accomplished things that
I only quietly dreamed about
for my whole life, and
if I learned anything
it's just that, there is no ready.
There is no such thing as ready.
There's only such a thing
as right here and right now.
If you're too scared
to go pursue the things
that you wanna do with your
life, what's the point?
What is the point of living
if you're not gonna live it
the way that you want?
I was ecstatic to cross off every item off
that last bucket list, but there's still
a million things that I wanna do.
So, I made a new bucket list.
(acoustic music)
Hello again.
What's up, man?
(acoustic music)